I know the music that's actor John David
Washington well you didn't see him but
that music is from ballers he's well
known for playing there he is
football player Ricky Jarret and that's
doing the rock Johnson on the HBO hit
series ballers it's a great show
where's Roland Spike Lee's film black
Klansmen and wash Washington received
his first Golden Globe nomination for
Best Actor we love when that happens
it's based on a true story Washington
place Ron Stallworth who was here he's a
first black detective in the Colorado
Springs Police Department Stallworth
sets out to infiltrate and expose the Ku
Klux Klan
during the 1970s how do you propose to
make this investigation will have
established contact and created some
familiarity with the Klansmen over the
phone I'll continue in that role but
only another officer surprise surprise a
white officer to play me when they meet
face to face that's my point exactly
chief black Ron Stallworth over the
phone white Ron stallworth face to face
over there becomes a combine Ron
Stallworth can you do that I believe we
can with the right white man we can do
anything today I'm the only way John
David I have to say congratulations to
you because this movies knockout and
what's so fascinating is it's a true
story yes when I first heard it I
thought this can't possibly be true yes
yes but you heard about Spike Lee they
say it's a family friend so people say
well of course he's gonna get the role
but that's not how that went down no I
know it is and I actually got to do a
movie that was in Sundance last year for
his wife Tanya yeah it's called monster
playing a psychopath from New Jersey so
he was familiar with that and my work on
ballers yeah and so I got a text from
Spike Lee saying oh this spike called me
and I've never talked to him on a cell
phone before I didn't even know he had
my number yeah obviously I'm surprised
and thinking it was a prank
uh-huh it was worth investigating for
sure it is yeah
you never know so I called him and I
like hello like he's like John spike hey
spike and he you know he told me about
this bookie soft pitch the story and I'm
thinking like okay this is definitely
the day Chappell scared of white
supremacists yes but I'll go with it
anyway Spike Lee Jordan Peele he sends
me the book I read it I called him a
week later say this is unbelievable I
can't believe this happened and he asked
me if I loved it I said I loved it and
said bet I'll see you this summer yeah
we got started so what was it like John
David meeting the real character and and
talking to him yeah Ron stallworth he's
an amazing man he's a true American Hero
he was very generous with his time and
information and I got a great deal of
insight on the case in him as a person
where he stood as a black man in
Colorado Springs you know in the 70s and
being the first ever African American
detective in that's in that town so I
got a lot of information he keeps his
card on them at all times
somebody David Duke his membership card
he he acquired from David Duke so I just
got a lot of information from him and
was it made it easier to be able to
become him it touches on racism it
touches on anti-semitism and this all
took place decades ago and yet as we all
know this is an issue that we're dealing
with today and the movie I don't want to
give too much away but the movie touches
on what we're facing today - in a very
surprising way a lot of people didn't
expect to see a real-time footage from
Charlotte's role in the film what was
your reaction to that because when I saw
in the theater it was silence yeah why I
gotta say but building up to that point
I mean it's just surprisingly given the
subject matter how heavy it is
surprisingly entertaining I mean a lot
of people are laughing and these
theatres in the theater yeah so it was
gut-punching though when you see the end
and you're seeing how spike connected
you know what's going on now and what's
been going on for a long time it was you
know can can I just say this is such a
good year for you because you've got
you've received the Hollywood breakout
performance award at the Hollywood film
award ceremony Congrats your first
Golden Globe nomination Congrats
Congrats thank you but most people
thought of you as a football player when
did you decide you wanted to make the
change from football to sports and did
you feel pressure because of your family
lineage oh man your dad yes yes thank
you for me
my mom you love your mind yeah I love it
too thank you thank you don't have this
but but yeah I I wanted to act my whole
life seeing my father do Shakespeare in
the Park when I was five years old
seeing my mother be able to sit down to
play any number on the piano I wanted I
wanted to do it because of who I was
related to and seeing his ascension into
the business I started trying to protect
my feelings and see how people treated
me differently so I chose football yeah
I got a injury kilise injury five years
ago and that's when I got it we're
getting ready Joe against the wall but
we're John David rising thank you we'll
be right there
[Music]